Major breaking news as the Donald Trump,
Pam Bonnie, Department of Justice are on
the attack trying to shut down yet
another AR-15 semi-automatic rifle ban.
This time in the District of Columbia.
Major fight going on right here, right
now. A major brief has just been filed
on behalf of Harmy Dylan, the head of
the DOJ, Office of Civil Rights, in
favor of the Second Amendment right to
keep and bear arms. Let's break down
this huge filing and this huge fight in
the District of Columbia, which will
have a ripple effect on all of our
rights across this great country. We'll
talk about it when we come right back.
Hey folks, it's Mark Smith, host of the
four box of dire proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and proud to say the top voice of the
second amendment in America. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. This is a big deal. Big deal. The
government of the District of Columbia
is trying to save its ban on
semi-automatic rifles. Rifles such as
the AK-47, AR-15, and the like. They're
trying to save their ban, but it's not
looking very good for them because the
Department of Justice under Pam Bonnie
and Donald Trump have just filed a huge
brief arguing that indeed the Department
of Justice can use civil rights laws to
vindicate our right to keep in arms, to
vindicate our Second Amendment rights,
and point out that DC's arguments as to
why that's not doable all fail. Just to
jog your memory, the District Columbia
has a ban on semi-automatic rifles,
AR-15s, and the like. If you try to
register them and set aside the
registration issue for a separate video.
Uh, but if you try to register them in
DC, they will not allow you to do it.
And if you're caught with one of these
rifles in DC, you get to go to prison
for, I think, upwards of a year. Well,
the Donald Trump Pam Bonnie Harmy Dylan
Department of Justice has sued DC saying
this violates the right to keep
environments. It violates the Second
Amendment and they're using a law uh
section 12601 under 40 under title 34.
You don't need to know those details
beyond the following that Congress
enacted a law that said the Department
of Justice is able to go after local
government officials if there is a
pattern and practice of misconduct that
violates among other things the rights
of American citizens. So, the Department
of Justice is arguing that there is a
pattern and practice by the government
of the District of Columbia and their
law enforcement agents to violate the
Second Amendment rights of Americans by
denying them, meaning the Americans, the
ability to possess commonly owned
semi-automatic rifles such as AR-15s.
And DC filed a MOTION SAYING, "OH, NO.
DOJ lacks the authority to enforce civil
rights laws. The only civil rights laws
that the DOJ is allowed to enforce are
those that hate on cops
and deal with the Fourth Amendment.
Any other constitutional right that we,
the government, decide to infringe upon,
the federal department of justice, lacks
the legal authority to do anything about
it. Well, of course, this is entirely
hoie
because if you read the statute, which
I'll read you in just a second, it's
clear that the United States Department
of Justice today under Pam Bondi has
complete legal authority to go after
local law enforcement to go after local
governments to the extent there is a
pattern and practice of them violating
any fundamental constitutional right of
which one example would be the right to
bear arms as the Supreme Court has
repeatedly said in second amendment
litigation. So, after being sued by the
Trump Department of Justice, the
District of Columbia filed a motion
dismissed, saying that the DOJ lacks
legal authority to even bring this case.
Well, the DOJ has just responded saying,
"You guys are wrong. Here's how DOJ
under Pam Bonnie, Donald Trump, and
Harmy Dylan opens up their brief
basically saying the DO basically saying
to the District Columbia, you guys are
wrong." And here's why. Check it out.
This case is straightforward. Relevant
here. Section 12601 makes it unlawful
for any governmental authority or any
agent thereof to engage any pattern or
practice of conduct by law enforcement
officers that deprise persons of rights
secured or protected by the United
States Constitution. Defendants do not
dispute that number one, the District of
Columbia is a governmental authority.
Number two, Chief Carol and the
Metropolitan Police Department are its
agents. Three, Chief Carol and the
Metropolitan Police Department are
acting on behalf when they are guess
what? enforcing the district's laws. And
four, the district's law enforcement
officers routinely enforce its so-called
assault weapons ban. If the assault
weapons ban is unconstitutional, as the
United States asserts, then the United
States prevails under section 12601
based on these undisputed facts. Of
course, whether the assault weapons ban
is unconstitute is for the court to
decide based on a robustly developed
factual record, not for defendants to
assume for purposes of their motion to
dismiss. Instead, the defendants,
meaning the District of Columbia and
their Amiki, take umbrage with the fact,
listen carefully folks, take umbrage
with the fact that section 12601
protects the fundamental constitutional
right to keep and bear arms from law
enforcement misconduct. Their desire to
limit the statute's protection to
exclude a right that they disfavor,
however, is not a valid ground to
dismiss the United States government's
complaint against them. Exactly right.
You see what's going on here? DOJ
historically has gone after, I don't
know, schools that, let's say, um, um,
enforce segregation of the races among
students and things like that. Uh, maybe
they've sued police officers for claims
of excessive force in Minneapolis or in
California. Uh, any of those sorts of
things. But what's what's now happening
is thanks to the wisdom of Harmy Dylan
and Pam Bonnie and Donald Trump is
they're using the Department of Justice
to laser focus on bolstering and
protecting the Second Amendment right to
keep March because it's a fundamental
right on par with like the Fourth
Amendment right against warrantly
searches and and unreasonable searches
and seizures and all that stuff. So the
bottom line is that the lefties, the
anti- gunners are upset that the DOJ is
vindicating or trying to vindicate in
court the Second Amendment right to keep
arms in the same way the DOJ has
historically vindicated other
constitutional rights. And here's what
the Department of Justice has to say in
favor of our Second Amendment rights, in
favor of knocking out this ban on
AR-15s. Check it out. The District of
Columbia's motion to dismiss must fail
because the Department of Justice has
plausibly alleged a cause of action
under section 12601 that the defendant
government actors pattern or practice of
law enforcement misconduct deprivives
persons of their Second Amendment
rights. And as the Supreme Court made
clear to Washington DC in Heler, the
Second Amendment right to keep and bear
arms is just such a constitutional right
for lawabiding citizens. Exactly right.
And by the way, just for you to geek out
on, I'm quoting William Kirk on that
one. He likes to geek out on. I don't
know where that phrase came from. Uh I
prefer being geeky, but you know, we all
have our uh strengths and weaknesses and
preferences. So, with that said, here's
the statute that the DOJ is using to go
after the anti-guners in the District
Columbia government. Check it out.
Section 12601 states in pertinent part,
unlawful conduct, it shall be unlawful
for any governmental authority or any
agent thereof or any person acting on
behalf of a governmental authority to
engage in a pattern or practice of
conduct by law enforcement officers.
that, listen carefully folks, that
deprive persons of rights, privileges,
or immunities
secured or protected by the Constitution
or the laws of the United States. Uh-oh.
Well, what is an example, an
illustration of a right protected by the
United States Constitution? Oh, I don't
know. How about the second amendment to
the constitution that's literally
written into the document? The right of
the people to keep in arms shall not be
infringed. And as interpreted by the by
the Supreme Court repeatedly, it is a
fundamental right on par with all other
fundamental rights. So I would think
that falls within the statutory
definition of what the Department of
Justice is able to go out and enforce
against local and state law enforcement
officers that are misbehaving and not
respecting such fundamental federal
rights. That's right. But DC is trying
to dodge this bullet, proverbically, of
course, and they're trying to say, "Oh,
no. You don't have that authority." And
they're probably going to get spanked on
the DUPA, and they're not going to win.
Nevertheless, I should also point out in
this brief, the Department of Justice
just did an excellent job arguing why
AR-15 semi-automatic rifle bans violate
the Second Amendment. Here's what they
have to say. Point out that DC's law
clearly violates the Second Amendment.
And the fact that they're enforcing it
constitutes a pattern and practice of a
state government violating, you guessed
it, the Constitution. Check out what
they have to say right here. Section
12601's protection of constitutional
rights includes the individual right to
bear arms. The second amendment provides
the fundamental protection of the right
to bear arms, a right that is no lesser
than any other constitutional rights,
which section 12601 protects against law
enforcement misconduct. In DC versus
Heler, the court ruled that the Second
Amendment must be interpreted in light
of the Constitution's text, history, and
tradition. The court also held that the
Second Amendment protects those weapons
that are in common use by law-abiding
citizens. Handguns are in common use by
law-abiding citizens. Therefore, the
court held that the district's handgun
ban violated the Second Amendment. The
court's later second amendment decisions
in Nerpa versus Breuan and US versus
Rahheem did not disturb the historically
based common use test with respect to
the possession of particular weapons.
It's very good. And by the way, you'll
see that the Department of Justice's
views
rhyme ring true for those of you who
follow the Four Boxes Diner channel. See
what I explained to you is if you follow
the four box of diner channel, guess
what? Your level of competency and
understanding of the Second Amendment
will be the highest levels of American
society. Just as high as the very good
right now US Department of Justice and
the arguments they're making. Let me
give you some other language from this
DOJ brief on behalf of Donald Trump and
Pam Bonnie and Harmy Dylan, and you tell
me if it sounds familiar to what you've
been learning about on this channel for
the last several years. Check out what
they argue next about AR-15 bans. AR-15s
are clearly arms under the Second
Amendment's plain text. In Heler, the
court has held that the term arms covers
all weapons of offense or armor of
defense. Thus, the second amendment
extends primapacia to all instruments
that constitute bearable arms, even
those that were not in existence at the
time of the founding. Goes on to say
that AR-15s fall squarely within this
category. Sounds familiar, right? And by
the way, remember how I explained to you
when I do major breaking news, some
people say, "I don't understand why is
this major breaking news?" It's because
I can see down the chessboard and a take
an Ewima let's say taking that hill
taking that mountain right in a war I
understand that that is a battle that
we've just won that we can use to launch
attacks on let's say I don't know
bombing Japan it's island hopping you
got to battle by battle by battle brick
by brick by brick president by president
by president and that is how we have to
fight to win the war ultimately which of
course will never end because people
will always want to take away our arms
because they want to do bad things to
us. So, with that said, remember how
there's some great cases in the past
that we've won. People are like, "Why is
this a big deal, Mark?" Now, you're
going to see why. Because when I talk
about these cases and what even the
liberal justices on the Supreme Court
have said, you'll see how these bricks
are now coming into play used by the
Department of Justice to shut down the
anti-gun efforts of the District of
Columbia. Check out what this brief has
to say in favor of our Second Amendment
rights right here, right now. In the
Supreme Court case of Smith and Wesson
versus Mexico, the Supreme Court
rejected Mexico's argument that it could
sue the manufacturers of AR-15s because
they are military style assault weapons.
The Supreme Court rejected that argument
because AR-15s are widely legal and
owned by ordinary citizens.
Specifically, Justice Kagan, that's
right, Justice Kagan writing for the
court stated, quote, finally Mexico's
allegations about the manufacturer's
design and marketing decisions add
nothing to consequence. As noted above,
Mexico here focuses on the manufacturers
production of military-style assault
weapons, among which it includes AR-15
rifles and AK-47 rifles. But those
products are both widely legal and
bought by many ordinary consumers
and manufacturers cannot be charged with
assisting in criminal acts just because
Mexican cartel members like those guns,
too. Exactly. Right. You see how a
statement made by the left-wingers on
the court, including Justice Kagan, in
the Mexico case,
we can now use today to win for our
rights. This is why I I talked to you
about these little battles that may not
appear to be a big deal on a random
Tuesday in March or April, let's say,
but I can see how they are going to be
used down the road to win major fights
in front of, let's say, the Supreme
Court to make it the law of the land.
So, here's another example where I've
always explained that the descent by
then Judge Brett Kavanaaugh in the Heler
2 case is going to be something that's
going to keep coming back in our favor.
And yes, indeed, it's reared its head
yet again. Check out what this brief has
to say about that descent by then Judge
now Justice Brett Kavanaaugh and the
Second Amendment. In Hiller versus DC at
the Court of Appeals level in DC, then
Judge Brett Kavanaaugh anticipated
Bruins text and history approach to
Second Amendment analysis. Employing
that analysis, he concluded that AR-15s
are in common use and therefore
protected by the Second Amendment.
Moreover, under the Supreme Court Second
Amendment precedence, it is anal
analytically difficult to distinguish
the AR-15s at issue here from the
handguns at issue in Heler. After all,
AR-15s are semi-automatic, but so too
are most handguns. law-abiding citizens
use both AR-15s and hangments for a
variety of lawful purposes, including
self-defense in the home. Accordingly,
Supreme Court president is clear. The
Second Amendment provides an individual
right to bear arms recognized within the
amendment's history and tradition. And
here the Department of Justice has
adequately pled that the defendants,
meaning DC and the government agencies
there, have engaged in a pattern
practice of a law enforcement misconduct
in depriving lawful gun owners of their
right to bear arms, including a R15s
that are covered by the Second
Amendment's plain text. Exactly. Right.
So here you see how prior decisions the
Mexico case the Supreme Court justice
now then judge now justice Brett
Kavanagh's com you know descent in Heler
2 in 2000 you see how these things get
grabbed and used brick by brick
president by president to advance our
right to keep and bear arms and I don't
love the fact it takes so long it's
terrible that we live in this world
where like you know 40% of Americans
seem to hate America as I understand it
but what can we do we have to do the
best uh with a hand that's being dealt
and the trend overall is our friend
although nothing's perfect in this world
but we're going to keep right on
fighting. So with that said we have to
applaud the Donald Trump Pam Bonnie
Harmy Department of Justice for fighting
for our second amendment rights in DC
and beyond. And again it's great to see
because to me of all the second amen
second amendment issues that are out
there that I want to win more than
anything else is knocking out all the
bans on AR-15s AK-47s semi-automatic
rifles. That would be a massive victory
and properly so for the Second Amendment
movement in America. Uh there's other
big issues, but this is the issue we
must win next in my view and I think
we're going to do it and hopefully
within the next 12 months, fingers
crossed, candles lit. All right, there
you have it, folks. I'll put a link to
the DOJ brief in the description of this
video like I usually do. And thank you
for tuning in. Make sure you follow me
over there on X for Boxes Downer. Don't
forget to subscribe both the YouTube and
the Rumble and I'll talk to all of you
again real soon here at the Poor Boxes
Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.